okay let's see if this is up and running
maybe sorta kinda almost yes yes yes yes
there we go
hey everybody so yeah little bit of a
little bit of a different look I've got
other videos that I'm shooting after the
live stream is over that I was I wanted
to get Donna for before our you know in
advance
otherwise it was gonna be up on tonight
so hi all right 5 p.m. in Idaho Thank
You Molly
thank you very much Betsy I'll take it
no what what do you mean no water do you
take me for
thank you Karen
so as you can probably guess from the
title of the live stream focus will be
on Doctor Who and the stuff that's been
going on lately cuz they're like it's
all how to stop um it's kind of nuts um
obviously as is my want over the next
hour
things will jump all over the place and
yes this will also serve as your
reminder the live streams are now every
other week instead of every week I'm
just trying to get you know my life
under control and scheduled worth a darn
it's uh it's a chore so I I have a glass
of Chianti however I'm missing the fava
beans and a liver
I find your command of words very
inspiring love your videos and keep on
me amazing Wow thank you that was funny
for me to hear considering how few my
videos are scripted so I guess I just
have addy
vocabulary off the top of my head I
guess that's all that's a reflection of
um in the same time zone hello from
Massachusetts oh there Freddie dr. who
right now is the Space Mountain of
roller coaster rides there's flashing
lights all right you have no idea where
it's going with damn it's fun that's not
a bad analogy to be honest I thought you
would hate how many mystery boxes it has
set up well see here's the thing and he
I think this is what people have not
grasped when I complain about the
mystery box it's not the presence of
elements that we will find more about
later
it was the rigid formula by which dr.
who would do it
which wasn't a series arc it was just
hey here's the thing that we won't
explain until the end and they would
just repeat it over the course of the
series until they got around to
explaining it usually at the finale so
you know the bad wolf is a good example
and it's the first one big [ __ ] you just
hear bad wolf over and over and over
again and you don't know why you just
hear it so much bad wolf but what is
being done right now is not why I
complain about because yes there are
more more elements being introduced that
I don't know what's going on but it's
not just going like look the timeless
child that's a mystery box because it's
a phrase with no meaning and no
relevance
until they explain it the existence of
another doctor while I don't know how
that happened that has immediate story
impact just saying the words timeless
child has zero impact until they get
around to explaining it the introduction
of a new doctor that has immediate
impact that impacts the story that I'm
watching right now and so it matters in
a way that just saying these things over
and over again just doesn't so I have to
keep clarifying and explaining
because people like oh there's so many
mystery boxes know for the kinds of
things that I mean when I say mystery
box there's just one it's the timeless
child there's a bunch of other stuff
that we don't have full backstory on yep
that's not the same thing all right oh
thank you very much CLP we don't know
where we're going the old man is snoring
keep your hands at your side stop the
ship uh it's it's something isn't it
this high holy cow I think this is the
most people in the chat have ever had
so I normally say I can't promise that I
will get to every question or what have
you and so that's standard this is
definitely a case where if you really
want me to grab something and I hate to
sound like I'm gatekeeping answering
questions the super chests gotta be your
friend because otherwise it might well
scroll past me holy crap I did not
realize there were this many people in
the chat Wow okay um I did catch that
somebody said that they that the lone
Dalek
I'm sorry lone Cyberman is a mystery box
sort of except that I at least know what
a Cyberman is I don't know why it's a
lone one I don't know why that's a
different threat from every other kind
of Cyberman but I do know what a
Cyberman is so that's like half a
mystery box after that phrase has
meaning to me which is more than a lot
of these things are my biggest fear in
comparison between doctors unfair to
Jody um that's an interesting point I'm
not entirely sure what to think about
that one way or the other
I think it's unfortunate and the I'm not
sure the show could really help how
contentious Jody's time has been and in
that environment yes there's an argument
to be made that perhaps the bringing in
another doctor to force an immediate
comparison and possibly make people wish
that they had this doctor instead
maybe wasn't a great idea and would have
landed as a broad concept better with a
less contentious era for the doctor in
question whoever that happens to be but
at the same time I think that given that
they have been fairly smart about it
I do think I think it would have been a
very bad look if this new doctor was a
man and I'm not saying that because I
never want a man to be the doctor again
I mean that because that would truly
force a very awkward conversation in the
fandom whereas by having it be another
woman that part of it doesn't be doesn't
enter into the discussion and people may
still go I like Joe Martin's doctor
better than Jody Whitaker's but at the
very least the idea of I want this man
instead of this woman at least that's
not a part of the conversation so you
know all things considered given what
you're saying I think has some validity
I think it's the casting sort of tackles
it about as well as it can be held um
thank you
cosmic paladin who is your favorite
doctor at present and I put that caveat
on there because it has changed in the
past it may well change in the future
at present my favorite doctor is Peter
Capaldi which is funny because I didn't
I didn't really take to him right off he
grow on me over time but then part of
him it's part of the characterization
changing and feeling like the character
was actually evolving as opposed to
being you know fairly fixed for his
whole time actually became a big part of
what I really loved about him and so
there's this kind of um there's this
kind of personal things wrapped up and
that the fact that you know he he came
about and was allowed to change and how
he ended his time was not how he started
it and
yeah that resonates with me can't
imagine why
I feel like casting an all-white woman
is the doctor and having her not be the
next incarnation would be a pretty
crummy thing to do for the show I'm
hoping she's 14 who forgot 13 yeah that
is gonna be an interesting question if
Joe Martin ends up not being the doctor
immediately following Whitaker then that
that is gonna be an awkward thing
because if they cast somebody else I
suppose depending on what happens with
the storyline and how much you say I
should get out of her but there's always
gonna be some folks who are like I
wanted her if they end up going
somewhere else when Jodie actually
leaves the part so that'll be an
interesting question why isn't the extra
doctor be referred to as dr. Ruth Google
dr. Ruth and figure out why they aren't
doing that let's see don't we already
know every shading every shady thing the
founding fathers did from Zagreus and
Omega I don't see what they could have
done that the master didn't know about
until recently well here's the thing to
keep in mind and this is something that
hardcore fans and I run into this with
Star Wars as well need to bear in mind
most people who are fans do not partake
of all the extra material so in the case
of Doctor Who that means comics novels
Big Finish most people who are fans
because I'm not I will not do the whole
you're not a real fan unless the thing
people who are fans don't know any of
that stuff they don't know the Omega yo
audio or meteora or as ligarius
or any of that and the show is not
beholden to it the show was allowed to
contradict it because the show is the
ultimate canon other stuff tries to keep
in continuity with the show the show is
not obligated to stay in continuity with
anything else which I was something god
I had this particular discussion with
people
since the frigging 90s because I
remember when Star Wars Episode one
came out I had friends who were super
into the extra Star Wars material and
they were like oh but I already know
it's gonna be an episode one because all
of these books and comics or whatever
covered that time period and I to
explain to them George Lucas doesn't
care he's gonna do his own thing and
that's gonna be it he's not going to
rearrange his plans for a movie based
off what happened in issue 7 of a comic
book miniseries and it's the same thing
with Doctor Who the showrunners are not
going to alter their plans based off
what Big Finish did are based on what
the novels are doing now they may borrow
from those they may take inspiration or
even storylines from them they have in
the past but they're certainly not
beholden to honor them as canon and they
won't I'm also reminded of Kendra the
Jamaican Vampire Slayer
oh that's an interesting comparison Oh
mr. pointy could they not tick off the
incarnations they both remember being
hopefully with offensive caricatures on
a white board I'm not entirely sure that
questions getting at so oh my god 300
people holy Wow hi way more people that
are usually in my live stream Wow um
mm-hmm
glad I look good tonight
the lone Cyberman could be Missy she
could have been converted after the
doctor falls and she wants a new body we
could be about see the origins of the Oh
master I saw somebody mentioned that and
it might have been you been
I cannot remember cuz I I can almost
never remember who leaves what comments
so I did see that brought up in the
comments on today's video that
possibility and like I I doubt it um for
a couple of reasons the first being
Michelle Gomez seemed pretty firm and
that she was done doing Doctor Who when
she left but beyond that I mean I I
wouldn't want that there wasn't really I
can't believe her a reason why they
wouldn't do that
except that like Missy story did feel
very complete and I suppose it could be
though it would always be execution
dependent what I say I don't want them
to do something it doesn't mean I'm
automatically gonna hate it if they do
it maybe they do it and they pull it off
hey that would be amazing but that would
make me nervous don't always agree but
your grounding force for me Oh Thank You
Vanessa you always look good Oh Freddie
you flatterer as in Ruth and thirteen
going through a list of passing
carnations they remember to see where
they diverge oh okay
find the most recent silly costume they
both feel embarrassed about oh okay I
follow you now that's a cute idea
actually I kind of like that you do
indeed look lovely oh I wasn't actually
fishing for compliments but thank you
I'm nervous because so far every finale
in the second series for each doctor has
been controversial hellbent wedding of
River Song last of the Timelords
I'm not sure that's really a pattern
though I think that's part of that um
might also be the fact that when you're
dealing with the second city
most of those also had stronger first
series for each of those doctors then I
would argue series 11 was so I don't
think that's altogether atypical that
you know you you hit the ground running
with a new thing and it does well and
then you get cocky and screw things up
whereas I don't that I don't know I say
this I don't get that same sense from
series 12 that said series 12 seems way
more confident in itself and what it's
doing than series 11 did we'll see they
seem to be juggling a lot let's see
would you like to see a return of any of
the old doctors for a season or more
especially Eccleston um I mean I would
love to see Eccleston in an episode
again um I would love to see Capaldi and
episode again I don't the thing is I
don't really get overly hung up on the
idea of the old doctors coming back I'll
get excited for it if it gets announced
probably get excited for it but I always
worry about the show
looking back too much because then it
runs the risk of becoming what Star Trek
became for a long time or it just keeps
aping old stuff and won't move forward
which Star Trek hasn't done until
friggin Picard started like just a week
ago so I worry about that when something
just keeps going back instead of trying
to move forward it becomes it just stops
evolving and that always worries me so
while I'd be up for appearances from
older doctors I frequently see the idea
floated that you know we get a series of
you know a new series with an old doctor
I just don't like that idea
because then amongst other things you're
gonna end up with this whole notion of
which is the real Doctor Who show is
that the one following the current
doctor the one that's going back and
going with an old doctor and it's part
of the same reason that as much as I
love him in the part I don't think it
would be a good idea for the health of
the show overall to give Paul McGann a
full season I'm sorry I just don't and
part of that may be because I have
swathes of 8th doctor Big Finish stuff
that I'm more than happy with so I feel
like I get a good solid Eighth Doctor
experience I get why more people want
him to have more time on the show I do
get it but I do think it would be bad
for the life of the show overall for the
health of the franchise for that to be
the case on the show things like Big
Finish and comics are actually great for
that because they're not beholden to the
continuity and not as many people follow
them so they can do that kind of stuff
that might be a bad idea for the show so
as much as I kind of dunked on the
debatable callosity of things like Big
Finish and the comics and whatnot I do
relish the fact that they exist so that
things like that can happen you need to
cosplay the dr. Ruth blouse I oh boy I
wonder I haven't I haven't started
looking as to whether her outfit is is
out there I can I be completely honest
though even if I could get scream
accurate ie
and this is not me discouraging anyone
else from doing it but I don't know if
I'd be comfortable cause playing the Joe
Martin doctor because she is a person of
color so the position on cross Rachael
cosplay can be a contentious one
and where I tend to land personally is
as long as you are not altering the
shade of your skin from my perspective
it shouldn't be that big of an issue the
instant you alter the shade of your skin
and it's and it's an actual shade of
skin that people have like you paint
yourself green to be Gomorrah fine go
nuts but once you start getting into
actually altering the shade of your skin
too especially too dark in it just don't
just like don't ever but that's only my
perspective and there are people who
hold the position that particularly
white people should not be cosplaying as
black characters full-stop even if you
don't even if you aren't darkening your
skin and I don't know if I hold that
position but I know enough about it as a
point of contention that I wouldn't feel
comfortable cosplaying as that doctor
which I don't like and and again that's
not me feeling like people would judge
me the PC police not like for me myself
I would feel off it wouldn't quite feel
right for me for myself to do that I
wouldn't be fully comfortable doing it
and that does blow me out of because I
think her look is great I think that's a
great costume it's terrific well thank
you am or my PME
I don't know pronunciations are a pain
great episode but I hope this doesn't
turn into a sixth season situation too
much stuff but not structure properly
and it fails miserably in the end having
recently finished my rewatch of series
six that is a valid concern I don't if
it falls apart I don't think it'll be in
the same way because even though
Chibnall is introducing a lot of things
and he's juggling a lot of balls in the
air right now um he doesn't seem to be
going for the time bending the sort of
twisting of the narrative that Moffat
was trying to
off which was part of the issue with
Siri six is that he had so much going on
that was you know tiny whining me and
bending of the narrative of space and
time as a whole that it just it all kind
of caved in on itself by the end of that
series and I'm not gonna say it's
impossible for something similar to
happen to chip though but I don't think
he's the way in which he's going big
reminds me way more of Russell than it
does of Moffett I think that might be
the more succinct way for me to put it
what I didn't get about age of steel in
season two where was the other universe
doctor could he not handle the Cybermen
oh okay I'd somebody else brought that
up as well so I don't I don't think it's
canon in the show so take it with a
grain of salt but a possible explanation
is that part of what the eye of harmony
does which basically grounds the time
travel technology of the Time Lords
is it also routes them to a single
reality where there aren't supposed to
be that's not to say it's impossible but
there are not supposed to be time
travelers in other dimensions they've
basically anchored that entire ability
to jump time to the reality in which the
Time Lords exist now again how can and
that is or isn't mm-hmm
did it varies and that's bendable and
flexible so who knows ultimately what
will be the answer but the other thing
to keep in mind is is that doctor who
has very rarely dealt with flat-out
parallel Earth's
very often we've dealt with other
dimensions you know sort of bubble
universes and you know places out of
space and time but actual parallels not
a ton it hasn't come up all that often
one Cyberman is cyber Li from Torchwood
oh dear God oh that outfit I said
wouldn't gone back and looked at that
costume lately Oh
Oh God joking aside Gomez doesn't have
to return if the Masters converted
regeneration in the suits which would
damage it and the one would hop out I
mean I guess you could do that John but
the thing is if you do it that way
what's the point like I don't see the
point of even a reference saying that
the lone Cyberman is Missy if you're not
gonna show Missy like that's that's just
being mean given how much I love Missy
that's mean
do you enjoy the really old who or does
the problematic stuff take you out of it
like the original doctor said something
Red Indians thinking trains are magic in
the first episode um honestly my biggest
hurdle with classic who is usually the
production quality and like I I can't
make allowances for it
I can make allowances for the fact that
it's not going to look like Star Wars or
even Star Trek of the same era but there
are times I'm like look not only does
you know it's one thing that they
couldn't make something perfect and
flawless but like that that piece of it
that piece of equipment supposed to be
rooted into the round is what roots of
the ground is wobbling back and forth
like that's just cheap that's not on a
budget that's just flat-out Chi there is
a difference between working on a budget
and looking cheap so that's a big hurdle
for me as far as the sort of problematic
stuff that you mentioned um it doesn't
hamper my ability to enjoy classic who
it can take me out of it from time to
time and it has with with black orchid
which I saw recently which has a
character who is the characters
Brazilian called an Indian played by an
Egyptian with this very fake big lip
disc and that was the little ooh okay
and then there was a nervous playing out
of the spiders had a guy in yellow face
um like it doesn't destroy the narrative
for me I will still try and evaluate the
episodes as best I can on the
understanding that that's kind of that
was of the time but it does kind of take
me out of it in the moment
certainly when that sort of stuff comes
up ah I've been catching up with classic
ooh lately I found I tend to not become
invested in a serial until the second
half is that weird um I'm not really
because Doctor Who being as serialized
as it was the classic era it usually
took time usually one or two episodes to
get you invested in the characters of
any given story so it it's paced in a
way that you're kind of not expected to
be that invested right out of the gate
because they have more time so they have
the time and they use it accordingly oh
hey hi Ian fashion of the nerd which is
a great channel if you folks have not
ever checked that out you should it's
very good amazing
Buffy content and also just a good
channel in general just saying hello and
wish I looked that good in purple cheers
hey cheers to you to Ian and otah Tracy
thank you um I'm so sick of Daleks and
Cybermen fair um do you think a season
without either could be successful yes I
know Season eleven didn't feature them
in the main only the special but we all
know how uneven season 11 was I mean yes
I think a series could be successful
without either one of them unfortunately
as you said the example we have that
didn't have either one is series 11
which had a lot of other problems and
it's it's it's one of the things that
really it's one of the it's probably my
biggest frustration
with steers 11 is that series 11 on
paper did so many things that I wanted
the show to do not have a mystery box
story art not have any returning
villains for the entire series to do
more self-contained stories all of these
were things I wanted the show to do and
it did them all and I still didn't like
the series not because of those things
but because mostly the writing wasn't
great for a lot of those episodes so
yeah I think it could work I think you
could absolutely work um you know I
think about the closest we came because
you you do you did still get some in
previous knew who that the pathology and
the Cybermen at least didn't factor into
the finale or the overall ongoing story
that's true of say series 6 which has it
has closing time which has the Cybermen
in it but that is detached from the
overall story and the overall story
deals with the silence again it's
frustratingly didn't particularly work
but I don't think it's because of a lack
of Daleks of Cybermen it's because the
story just didn't fully come together
the Dalek was perfect came back and was
defeated and not being an overarching
enemy I mean the Daleks part of the
issue with the Daleks especially at this
point I would say more so than the
Cybermen because since especially now
that they've established that Cybermen
keep popping up across the universe
basically in parallel evolution to each
other that means that they have a bit
more freedom in terms of how they depict
them unfortunately part of the core idea
of the Daleks is they don't change they
hate change they hate anything that
isn't them that said I do still think
there are some things that you could
do with them but by large they just
usually have an armada of Daleks show up
and we've seen that um I did actually
like resolution to have it be a single
Dalek in a cobbled together tank was a
neat idea I wish that the thing had a
had thrown together but was not as
powerful as it was I don't think it
should have been I think it should have
been more on the backfoot than it was by
the end of it but I still thought that
was a that was a solid idea as far as
that sort of thing went and it's it's
often the Cybermen and the Daleks
stories that don't quite work where I at
least liked the set up more than just
Dalek or Cyberman show up in a fleet so
like I like the idea behind victory of
the Daleks or even um Dahl examine
Hatton an evolution of the Daleks I like
those ideas of them you know trying to
rebuild trying to cobble something
together because they don't have their
full resources I feel like the concept
behind the Cybermen closing time it's
just these ideas keep getting stuck into
stories that don't execute but dang huh
oh well what can you do
thank you very much Thomas I appreciate
that thoughts on how to fix the
companions in the background issue I
would like a companion and dr.light
episode alluded to by yes with the
doctor dropping off the companion and
looking for the master I mean why my
heart answer is some of them have to go
my honest answer is we need to ditch
either yaz or both Ryan and Graham
because in my mind they're there they're
a bundle it either needs to be the
doctor with Ryan and Graham or the
doctor with yes having all three of them
there it's just not working so that good
so part of the reason that they're all
shunted to the background is the show's
try and balance time for all of them and
it just doesn't work like at all so you
know that's part of it but given that we
have all three right
now um I honestly don't know at this
point because part of the issue for me
is if you're gonna give anybody more
screen time I want more time with the
doctor
cuz I feel like I don't know Whitakers
doctor as well as I should by this point
so if we're gonna give anybody a
highlight I would much rather it be her
than any of the companions so yeah
that's that continues to be a
frustration uh Thank You Nina much
I think Chibnall is affected by the
criticism he claims otherwise
that's why series 12 is the way it is
the big revelation about the doctor you
know for so many years stuff rarely
works for me well the thing is we
haven't actually had a big revelation
yet we've had new master unexpected we
have now the Joe Martin doctor very
unexpected but until we get an
explanation of why that is
then it I think it's a little premature
to say that he is going back and
rewriting the doctor's history it is
distinctly possible that by the time we
get an answer that is what he will end
up doing and I am always going to be
nervous at anybody attempting to do that
because not even just with this because
it's the kind of thing that happens in
like um long-running comic book series
all the dang time and 99% of the time it
just is a bad idea
so that that does make me nervous and
it's it's part of why I really hope so
hard that Joe Martin's doctor is not pre
Hartnell because that is such a
fundamental rewrite of what we know
about the doctor I don't think you can
make it work that is rewriting too much
history and it's a big part of why
I don't like what they did with Clara
injecting her into the lives of every
single doctor that is you're changing
too much I don't think it's a good idea
I don't think it works but I'm not gonna
prejudge I'm nervous I'm not gonna
prejudge cuz I don't know what he
actually is doing I don't know what
actual mechanism he's put in narrative
Lee knew justify what has happened and
until I find out I'm not in a position
to say that it's failed or that it was a
bad idea I can express be nervous
and I am but for right now in the moment
I am having fun and I'm having a heck of
a lot more fun with that I was a series
11 and that's not nothing even if it
faced plans in the finale that's not
nothing when I listen to assert arabes
master audio I now think to myself
maximum Derek uh last night I caught up
on the good place which will be ending
soon huh that's just so good and yes I
will have my thoughts on the final
season of that once that wraps up so
what else we got here a real-life jolly
or possibly jolie I don't know uh
whichever it is thank you starting to
thinking but I have to ask worth a dang
is your kids still up still in earshot
actually my kids at our mother's tonight
it's habit at this point if I'm talking
in front of the camera it just it takes
a lot for me to swear because my I have
it very I've been doing this for so long
at this point it's very engrained in my
head if you swear you're making more
work for yourself into edit because
you're gonna have to bleep it now
granted this is live so I can't anyways
but there's also the risk of de
monetization because while it wouldn't
affect the super chats which I'm greatly
appreciated people are doing a lot more
tonight with and actually I'm super
appreciating that because I I made my
appointment to get my taxes done for
2019 that
um but anyways the archived version of
this can still get to monetize depending
on what is or isn't said by me in the
stream I've learned that the hard way
because I've had things that I talked
about like not even swearing just topics
that I broached that resulted in the and
the archived version of stream being
demonetised which yeah you swear words
from the good place oh yeah I mean that
that would work I I would have to like
I'd have to put so much effort into
thinking it to get it right though it'd
just be I just think my brain would keep
thing yeah this is bull shirt for kid
mm-hmm let's see here I know it's not
Doctor Who but you always say your
problems with the last Jedi aren't those
that everyone else has what problems do
you have because you know I love that
movie huh okay look I've got multiple
videos of about up on the last Jedi and
now is probably not the best time to ask
because I haven't really watched the
thing since it was in theaters so my
memories of it are hazy but my issues
with it are not raised nobody are not
force force magic Leia are not what is
done with Luke none of those things are
my issue my issue is with the thing
structurally both as a film in and of
itself and even more so now that series
episode nine has come out its place in
the overall trilogy and the series as a
whole because it's just so anomalous it
just doesn't fit and that doesn't make
it a bad movie but it does make it one
that I really don't enjoy at a
fundamental level I think Rian Johnson
Rian Johnson did what he always does in
virtually every movie he's ever made
he takes something that is a known
quantity deconstructs it and
reconfigures it into something that is a
commentary on itself is what he did with
time travel with looper it's what he did
with con movies with a brother with the
Brothers Bloom it's what he did with
murder mysteries with knives out and all
of those are movies I like knives out
freaking loved but the thing about
deconstruction is when you deconstruct
something by necessity you break it and
when you reassemble it it's not the same
thing that it was when you took it apart
which is why I think most of the great
deconstructionist work is either done as
pastiche --is or analogues
so like Watchmen is a deconstructionist
work and all of those characters are
analogous to preexisting superheroes or
there are alternate versions like
Superman red Sun is a good
deconstructionist text The Dark Knight
Returns is a good deconstructionist act
but again flash forward into the future
possible timeline alternate history the
best deconstructionist work is either
done with the tropes or done with
versions that you're allowed to break
alternate versions of characters past
ages of characters not the characters
themselves so I think the kind of
deconstruction that Brian Johnson just
does is what he doesn't every movies
ever made was just a bad fit to do with
the main saga and it's not to say I
wouldn't have wanted a Rian Johnson Star
Wars movie I just wish he hadn't been
given the existing characters so that's
that's sort of ultimately where I land
on that I don't think what he was trying
to do was a fundamentally bad idea but I
don't think it's
have been done with the characters as we
knew them I think that he if he was
going to break the narrative of how good
are the good guys how how bad are the
bad guys how gray is everything are the
Jedi even anything to aspire to if he
was got a toy with all that it should
have been he should have been allowed to
but like off somewhere else with a
different set of characters I mean
that's just kind of ultimately where I
am on that do you think dr. Ruth would
remember Jody if she is from her past by
the way blame yourself for viewing
numbers for being so fabulous thank you
um well I mean the the thing is neither
version of the doctor remembers the
other Jody doesn't remember Ruth Ruth
doesn't remember Whitaker
so uh something's off if it was just a
case of Ruth coming later she would
recognize Jodie Whittaker but she
doesn't so something's off something's
wrong which is why I kind of didn't
really even talk about the possibility
of her being the doctor that comes after
Whitaker because it just doesn't there's
so much of us is being put on the fact
that something is off and that seems too
straightforward if that makes sense I
see and yes it's Oh
Zoli realize Oh Lee thank you thank you
for that correction otherwise you do
just kind of roll the dice with me and
pronunciations all right thank you very
much for that generous folks this
evening I absolutely appreciate it do
you think the season will end in a way
so they can ignore the max amounts of
regeneration I mean the thing is the max
amount of regeneration aren't going to
come up for another 11 doctors anyways
and all they have to do at that point
and they can do it before if they want
to all they have to do was establish
that when the doctor was granted a new
regeneration
in time of the doctor that it was not a
regeneration cycle tethered to the
normal restraints in just one line of
dialogue you've got it covered but if
they don't want to tackle that they
don't have to because like I said
strictly speaking it's not going to come
up for another 11 doctors we're okay for
a while do you what do you think about
creators lying in interviews I hate it I
understand where the instinct comes from
when creators behind shows or comics or
what have you just straight-up lie to
fan questions or interviews or what have
you
I get why because they want to maintain
surprises and they're hoping to
misdirect the fan base so that they can
still surprise them the problem that I
have with that is I can respect
III can appreciate the position that it
that they get put in if they're doing
interviews and answering questions at
all and I can appreciate the difficulty
and how you how unsatisfying it is to
give an answer of you'll just have to
wait and see but I wish that is what
they would do because when they start
actively lying in interviews I feel that
is insulting to the audience you are
insulting the intelligence of the
audience and you are breaking a trust
that you don't you can only do that once
and it's why I will never ever ever
trust anything that JJ Abrams says about
any movie he has ever involved in prior
to it coming out I never will because
four star trek into darkness
he said repeatedly unequivocally that
Benedict Cumberbatch was not playing God
and he was and to lie to us when we all
guessed that immediately so that you
could then try and go when the movie
comes out oh we tricked you he really is
kind of like yeah we knew don't act like
you were clever we figured you out
and then you lied same thing with
Spector and Blofeld though that one was
even more insulting because there was
the backlash to con prior to that far
enough in advance that they should have
realized that was a bad idea so actually
SPECT you pissed me off more and other
in it happens in other mediums Tom King
this one pissed me off Tom King
insisting that Batman and Catwoman were
really going to get married and then
they just didn't or Marvel insisting
that Captain America being a secret
Hydra agent was real and canon and they
weren't doing any kind of alternate
reality of course they were don't lie to
us just say look you want to find out
keep reading keep watching find out
stick with us and you'll see don't lie
to us it's insulting thank you very much
Strom dynasty gaming yes Thank You
Carolyn okay I need to pop on over to
the discord real quick and see what
questions popped up there because and
here's here's the obligatory plug the
there is a council geeks discord it is a
patreon exclusive perk at the two dollar
support level and above so link for the
patreon is down in the description and
folks who submit questions through the
through the discord for the live streams
are guaranteed to have them answered
because they are already financially
supporting me so that that's a perk in
addition to the disk or itself just
being a perk in general so let me pop on
back over there see what I've got
um just kidding oh this is going to be
interesting how's Andy or wasn't able to
make it I I can't I mean especially with
this many people watching which is still
weird um like I haven't I haven't
scanned to see who was there but oh yeah
all right I think the series is a big
step up but I see a real parallel
between 13 and 5 or somewhat defiant
doctor identity the well played and too
many companions
oh so when you say 5 you mean
or maybe it's sorry some somewhat
different doctor so yeah I've seen the
comparisons made recently between Jodie
Whittaker and Peter Davidson's doctor
which might be valid if for no other
reason then maybe that would explain why
I'm not fully connecting with the
thirteenth doctor because I don't really
get the fifth doctor I mean I just kind
of don't so if they are trying to evoke
the fifth doctor specifically yeah that
would explain a bit if the whole thing
is a parallel slash multi-universe
situation do you think or want to see
all previous doctors from the other
universe in a flashback um it would be
kinda cute if they if it is big if and
apparently chip NOLA is now saying this
is not what's going on we'll see if
that's a flat-out lie or not but if it
is a parallel universe doctor situation
which I'm not sure how like this I'm
favoring my sort of split time thing
which is slightly different maybe I'm
being pedantic about that anyways if it
is that I think it would be kind of cute
if we had like a flash of the previous
incarnations of Joe Martin's doctor and
like they were all super famous uh-huh
actors like to just have tiny flashes
and like maybe one light from each of
them and just like get stupidly huge
names like like Ian McKellen or Benedict
Cumberbatch or Helen Mirren and till
this went and like all these people to
have been previous incarnations of that
doctor that would be cute and fun um I
think what would have to be if you were
gonna do that because if you got anyone
who could reasonably play the part
people will be clamoring well give us
that but if you did it as a gag with
names way too big to ever be the regular
doctor then people would appreciate that
that is what you are doing is it time
for the doctor to start caring at Apple
like a real fruit if this is a multiple
universe thing well you know what it is
my intention for for Towel Day this year
to do a video talking about whether or
not Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy and
doctor who are in continuity to what
degree arguments for and against cuz I
love both and there are some connections
uh thank you very much gamer Jamie I
love the job doc the Joe Martin doctor
already and unfortunately maybe more
than Jody's doctor also your lipstick is
a bit smudged in your right corner yeah
I actually did see that I was gonna
touch it up before I do video gonna have
to deal with that later thank you though
oh geez bookworm but we're a bookworm of
the fandoms thank you
Wow um you're my favorite doctor who
reviewed channel couldn't think of any
questions so happy Captain Jack is back
I am too although I now have the
disappointment of what Chibnall has said
about that which is saying that we're
not getting any more of Jack in the
series but maybe next series
that if true that's a little annoying
like it was great to have been back it
was wonderful and I loved it but like
that's it that's all that's all you have
planned to give us right now really dude
come on did you see the ship no leak
apologies trying to describe the leak so
you know what I'm talking about if you
do or don't know I am not sure what
you're talking about there you're Tom
this is a long shot but do you think the
timeless child might have something to
do with giant vampires Rassilon went to
war with them I don't know um I'd be
surprised that would be a bold choice
IIIi don't think so do you think there's
a danger of a separate but equal
minefield if hold on if she's not a
mainline incarnation who gets a series
or two I mean I think that's a bridge
we'll have to cross when we get to
whenever Jody decides she's done with
the part as to whether we get Joe Martin
or anyone else I'm not prepared to weigh
in on that question at this point it is
a bit of a bridge we're gonna have to
cross a bit like how I did a video last
year talking about whether or not the
next Doctor after Whitaker should be
another woman or not obviously you know
making allowances for we should have
someone who's good in the part and all
that but just broadly speaking
philosophically and making the argument
that it's probably best that the next
doctor be a woman as well because
otherwise we run the danger of her
basically being a flute and of people
shouting see they went back to a man
because a woman didn't work and you know
there's just optics involved that get
complicated I think there are some
potentially very complicated optics
around the Joe Martin
doctor especially if she does not take
over the part down the line again that
may or may not be mitigated depending on
what the storyline we ultimately get
with her now ends up being so let's take
a pin in that we'll see there's rumors
that Chibnall has cast martin now so she
can take over from jodi whatever Jodi
gets done with the role I mean III
believe you that that's the rumor I
don't truck with rumors here's here's
the logistical issue with that unless
Jodi has already definitive behind the
scenes has already definitively said
when she's leaving the part which is
possible but I don't know unless that's
happened and and it would have had to
have happened before they even shot
series 12 so unless she decided before
shooting series 12 I know exactly what
I'm leaving I don't think that that's
the case and here's why
any actor of stature is not gonna leave
a hole in their schedule you know she
could be doing other shows movies plays
whatever but if she was basically being
left on hold until Whitaker leaves the
part then that would mean that she would
basically have to have either a
permanent hole in her in her schedule to
allow for the possibility that it could
be any moment or she would have to be
prepared to drop anything else she was
doing in order to come over and do
Doctor Who neither of which i think is
very likely and really no professional
actor would agree to that so I think
that's the the the hole in that is the
real world logistics of booking an actor
which is something that I actually know
a little bit about having tried my hand
at acting and having friends who
actually have done some degree of
professional acting's
you know I actually get to talk to
experience when I talk a little bit
about that behind the scenes stuff I'm
plenty on cosplaying for local con I'm
thinking temp doctor on a student budget
what's your best tips or advice I don't
know because my entire 10th doctor stuff
is you know screen accurate and some of
the pieces were even bought by by fans
and sent to me like the like the coat
was so I think the cheapest thing you
could do the most budget conscious would
be to get a light blue button-down shirt
get the tie get the correct tie and the
sonic screwdriver and don't worry about
the jacket or the jacket matching the
pants and just have it be you know have
it be a little bit more shoveled as
whatever parts of the outfit you get as
long as those parts are fairly accurate
it being incomplete is not the biggest
issue in the world at least that's my
approach I'm surprises more than 300
people in live chic yeah you and me both
this this has been it's been a trip and
I am gonna be wrapping it up kinda
soonish
I got a backtrack though I've got I've
got questions waiting for me I was
expecting the Judoon to recite poetry to
be honest ha ha ha that would have been
fun um how do you see the idea of a more
famous bigger actor playing the doctor
but just in a special run of sort kind
of like the Tennant specials um like
aside from sort of a one-off jokey bit
kind of like I talked about earlier I'm
I don't think speaking personally I
would always much rather have more
episodes with an actor I've never heard
of before then fewer episodes with a big
name because if they cast it well then
the big name wouldn't do it any better
anyway if that makes any sense
like nobody knew who Matt Smith was and
I remember at the time I was hoping for
Bill Nighy who was a little bit too big
a name for the part and I can look back
and say yeah I would much rather have
had the three series of Smith than we
had then the four specials of Nighy like
that's just sort of where I land on that
um thank you very much chase as long as
the doctor is good they can regenerate
her into a dog or a doctor with two
heads or ginger ginger okay now I was
just talking crazy
I I don't even know what to say to that
[Laughter]
I am gonna be wrapping it up soon folks
so this has been wow this has been a
busy one um I want to send you a link to
the rumor if you're interested but can't
send links on here is there anywhere I
can send you the URL I mean at this
point Tom it's not gonna make the live
stream because I do need to wrap up cuz
I've got other stuff I got to do tonight
but if you want to hit me up through
email council the geeks at gmail.com or
if you want to DM me on twitter at
council of geeks I'll take a look at it
and tell you what I think but we're not
gonna make the live stream on it do you
think the loge Cybermen could be someone
jack knows that the doctor might not
like a certain hot friend of Jack's who
was formerly in Buffy boy I'm a ginger
hey look
Zoli it was a joke I have nothing
against gingers I had I have a friend
with an amazing burlesque performer who
is such a freaking ginger that it's her
performance named ginger lolly she's
amazing and I was just of the three
things he said the ginger was the most
viable and so it was the one that was
automatically funniest for me to act
like that was ridiculous
just made it under the wire American
Gods TV show have you seen it
I have not it has been on my to-do list
for ages and no I haven't got do it
I still haven't oh yeah I'm not racist
I've did your friends I swear oh god it
did come off like that didn't it
hey um so anyway backtracking to God
because I'm one I want to wrap up the
question of the lone Dalek so as much as
I would love to see James Marsters come
back into the universe in any capacity
um I don't I not who is the loan the
loan Cyberman is just something that my
brain just won't do because the thing is
like I can get my brain to roll with
figuring out ooh
where does this doctor fit into you know
the timeline or where does the master
fit in but things like who is the the
lone Cyberman like it's just a title so
I have nothing to work off of and
anything I think would just be literally
a wild guess and I get very bored at the
prospect of doing that so I really have
no thoughts on who the lone Cyberman is
if it even is anybody you know that we
would know uh I know really but still
the doctor wants to be ginger after all
well the tenth and eleventh wanted to be
ginger it hasn't come up since then and
tastes change we don't know if the
doctor still wants to be ginger that
said when if and when it ever happens I
do want the doctor to look in a mirror
and go I'm ginger
I don't like it not because gingers
aren't awesome but because it would be a
callback to the running gag of you've
redecorated I don't like it so I think
that would be a fun way to pay that off
if they are actually doing I do need to
wrap it up thank you everybody
so much this has been a great night
thank you all for coming way more people
that I think I've ever had on a life she
bar at the very least way more that I've
had in a long time
I'll be back on again in two weeks
depending on what happens in Doctor Who
that may be the topic again or it may be
something else depending on what else is
going on
but next live stream two weeks same time
same place so thank you so much all for
tuning in and just remember folks you're
beautiful you are valid you are loved
you are the counsel
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time
this council is adjourned have a good
night everybody